president biden has weighed in for the
first time on the scandal surrounding
new york governor andrew cuomo
who faces multiple allegations of sexual
harassment
now many democrats say cuomo should
resign now our national correspondent
jerica duncan is following this story
stepping off marine one the president
said that democrats should wait and see
do you think governor andrew coleman
should resign i think the
investigation is underway
and some lawmakers want action now so
far
18 new york congressional democrats have
called for cuomo to resign
including new york senators chuck
schumer and kirsten gillibrand
it's clear that governor cuomo has
lost the confidence of his governing
partners as well as the people of new
york
on friday a seventh woman accused the
governor of sexual harassment in a
personal essay
jessica bakeman writes that she didn't
think the governor wanted to have sex
with her
but that he wanted her to know she was
powerless the former albany reporter
says there were multiple occasions
where governor cuomo put his hands on
her arms shoulders the small of her back
and her waist and view of colleagues on
friday the governor again denied the
claims
that he inappropriately touched anyone i
never
harassed anyone i never abused anyone i
never assaulted anyone
now and i never would right and he's
adamant that it is not affecting his
ability to govern at a critical time for
the state
but according to the washington post new
york's vaccines are
larry schwartz has been phoning local
officials in order to gauge their
loyalty to the governor
according to the report one official
believed getting vaccines to his area
could
suffer if schwartz was not pleased with
his response
and the governor's office and schwartz
deny that the governor did
anything wrong schwartz told the post
that when he made those calls
it was not in his role as a vaccine czar
but
only as cuomo's friend tony
all right thank you very much we